[Musique]
il flotte comme un parfum de naphtaline
au fond de ce couloir dans cette salle
plus de 5000 éléments de costumes sont
délicatement ta ligne et capitaine
femmes du monde jeune bourgeois ou
enfants des rues ils sont tous là au
garde-à-vous reflet d'une époque où une
société
il témoigne en tout cas de la longue
histoire de l'opéra de tours mais déjà
il faut préparer les prochains modèles
alors là c'est la reine caroline c'est
pour le thé des hommes ça prend une
figurante qui pompera sportul dans le
thé des hommes chanter avec le coeur et
c'est là nous avons cardinal toujours
pareil avec une énorme cap comme ça donc
il ya aussi beaucoup de costumes dans
cet ouvrage qui ont été récupérés d'un
ancien tosca donc on fait les costumes 9
mais on a aussi essayé récupérer les
costumes aux stocks nous entrons dans
l'atelier de couture
ici c'est le royaume des petites mains
c'est cathy c'est aussi sur leur route
derrière on l'avait fiche de mesure des
artistes et on fait les costumes on
coupe les costumes aux mesures des
artistes après les artistes quand ils
arrivent au moins de la mise en scène
ont fait les essayages ayant fini les
costumes des costumes taille et tout
spécialement pour les chanteurs d'opéra
donc une vraie prouesse technique mais
qu'on veut fermer à col de chemise à un
homme dans tout de suite ils étouffent
avant d'avoir fermé donc on met quatre
tailles au dessus voilà on absolument
pas serrer le cou pour les garçons et
pour les femmes au niveau de vie vante
serra il faut une personne super d'être
serrée d'autres non et puis aussi des
mouvements parce que lorsqu'on doit
lever le bras etc
il faut pas être coincé par une aventure
donc il ya des astuces de costumier on
vous nous aidez souffler
[Musique]
alors quand on voit sur scène les
costumes que l'on à réaliser soi même on
ressent une pointe de fierté mais pas
seulement
on est heureux en ému en
et on a l'oeil très technique qu'il
réponde à ça qu'on le voit donc on
pouvait passer de l'opéra du coup
direction la salle d'essayage
il règne ici une certaine fébrilité une
calotte noire
ana ros cléa flore et romane sont de
jeunes recrues issues du conservatoire
c'est leur toute première expérience
scénique c'est trop cool et tant pis
pour les costumes de princesse pour la
tosca c'est un enfant de coeur qu'elles
apparaîtront